[grunts fearfully]
AHH! I see you over there!
What are you doing?
You better not be coming this way, I got a... flashlight!
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome-
-where are you guys?
Where are you at?
Hey guys!
Welcome! Welcome to my new, lit, setup!
Uhh! Kill it!
Uhh!
Ehh!
Alright, the only difference is that it's better lit.
That's literally the only thing that's going on here
But either way, welcome to the Brookhaven Experiment,
And the Brookhaven Experiment is a demo that I played a while ago
But now the full game is out, so happy-go-lucky for me...
So I'm gonna play through the campaign,
Because I'm pretty sure that the demo was about survival.
Well, I mean the whole game's about survival
I'm gonna die to zombies
But this one- BLAM!
I'm gonna play the campaign!
I should probably have the wrist straps on
Nah!
I like to live dangerously...
"Town square, lab observatory"
Ookay,
WUBAYUM!
Maybe I should've-
-Ohh
[high-pitched scream]
What's happened to me?
ooh
OHh!
Radio Voice: Hello, this is Kali,
Maintain radio silence and look out for hostiles.
Always check your six.  Over.
Mark: WHAT?
MAINTAIN RADIO WHAT? SILENCE? WHO?
Ohh god,
I gotta kill it with a Kukri!
It's called a Kukri, I know that from TF2!
Come at me bitch!
come at me huh kill it kill it kill it
Come at me!
Huh?
Kill it! x3
Slay!
Ohh shit!
Ow!
How 'bout, can-
oh
That didn't work as smoothly as I thought it was gonna...
Heyy, neighbor...
How you doin' out there?
Ohh I'll be with you in just a moment...
Kali: The tracker is active and I can see that you're in the old Fulton machining place.
Mark: Huh?
Kali: There are still enough active GPS satellites to get the job done.
I've got reports of a large herd of hostiles in your area.
Mark: A herrrd you say..?
Kali: You'd better unholster.  Over.
Mark: Unholster?
Ohh!
Oh, okay
Well I'm ready for this
"Squeeze grip buttons to reload"
You got it baby!
I'm ready for this!
I should-
Kali: I hope that gun of yours is loaded.
haha
Mark: Uhh...
Blffff
fllbl
It is now!
"Wave 1"
I didn't quite get the guy with mah Kukri, but I-
-ohh
I'm what did I got good luck charm
BLAM!
What did I got?
Good luck charm?
Well how does that help me?
How's that gonna help me against the, legions of the damned?
BOINK!
Uh hohohohohohoho~
You are dead~
Oh
Hi!
Hidy hidy ho
Hidy hidy, goodbye...
What the fuuuuuck?
Boink.
There we go, that's more appropriate
dur
Is that someone behind me?
Ha-bam.
oh boy huh
Ohhhh
Boink!
Huh
They seem to be coming very slowly
Mayybe I should handle you with my Kukri..?
Does reloading lose bullets?
No it does nooot!
Ahh!
Bitch bitch bitch!
Kali: Stick to listen only mode
Your voice will draw more of them to your position.
Mark: Listen only mode?
Kali: As long as you keep moving, that tracker will let me know you're still on mission.
keep moving that tracker will let you
know you're still on mission
Mark: Wait, lis-?
Kali: The sun is almost down. So take care of any remaining hostiles in that place, and get out of there.
Mark: Wait what was that ab-?
Kali: Over.
Mark: My voice?
You mean the lyrical softness of my booming voice?
Is gonna-
AHH!
WHAT THE FUCK??
Holy, shit balls!
Oh my god!
I was not prepared for that!
What the fuck!
Well we got danger-
Ohhheahhh!
[creepy machine noises]
Can I mention that this-
[loud creepy machine noise]
okay but can I mention that this
Okay, but can I mention that this-
[creepy machine noises continue]
Ughh
Can I mention that this doesn't
work very well?
I'll try that one
I don't need health
blfff
What am I, a scrub?
Bayum~!
"Defender, Specter, Lupara..."
None of these help me...
Hwabayummmmmmmmmm~! 🎵
buh-
"Bolt upgrade"?
"Buff upgrade"?
Ohhh the different upgrades, okay...
"Throwable upgrade, Bolt-on upgrade"
I can get nothing!
I'm good
Okay, so there's a lot more customization options
and I imagine that they've done a lot more polish on getting this game up and ready.
Hello friend!
You going to be joining me?
You better not-
Ohh, back off big momma!
huh I you should know that i'm
incredibly intimidating when i'm looking
Huh!
I'd, I, you should know that I'm incredibly intimidating when I'm-
Looking up at your crotch
Oh no
Oh no!
Oh no!!
OH NO!
shit
Ah!
There we go
That was more impressive
Wabayummmmm~! 🎵
mmm
What's that?
You wanna have a conversation?
No!
Aaaand no
Heh heh heh heh, heh~~~
Waaya are you doin'?
Waaya doin'!?
I don't think so
Reloading!
Huuh
Wuh
Do I hear the stippy-steppies of some losers?
Come at me scrubs!
Come at me!
Ohhh no!
You came and died!
Who's that over there-
nnnnnnnnn
Nope!
hehehehehehe
uhh
How 'bout a big nope
Man I'm too good f-
What the hell?
I didn't know what that was
I got the specter!
Dude! Come here I got somthin' to tell ya!
Blam!
I got the specter bruh!
Kali: from town square you'll see the lab,
It'll be dark, but you won't miss it.
Mark: Uh huh
Kali: Fire will light your way.
Mark: Town square huh?
Kali: Kali out.
Mark: Really...
Ohh, I can do a little bit of that.
I haven't been very mobile
I can move around a little more~
What do you want from me?
Huh?
*loud machine noise again*
Jesus!
*creepy noise continues*
I guess I'm done with that!
Well
So far, so goo.
I'm doing great!
Is everything still recording?
Gosh I hope so
If it's not I'm gonna be soo sad
Lemme just double check-
brb
ooh!
Are we done?
ooh!!
I did it!
I did it guyth!
Ohh boy!
ohh
heyy
It blew its load with that one jumpscare and it wants to give me-
Ohhhh we're back here
Kali: You can use your flashlight, if you're not already.
Mark: oh-oh.
okay
Good, it's better than the uh...
Kali: Not much use unless you turn it on.
Mark: hehe
heh
Kali: Don't turn that flashlight on unless you need it.
ok your battery whoo it's a lot darker
than the last time they were here know
Mark: Okay..!
Kali: You wanna conserve your batteries.
Mark: Oooh, it's a lot darker than the last time they were here
No!
Oooh, the Specter
"Lightweight, high rate of fire..."
Well I don't really need a lot of-
rate of fire...
Ummm
It's got the exact same firepower though so
they're pretty close enough that it doesn't matter
Alright, can I get any of these?
"Choose upgrade"...
nuh, locked
Buff
Ooh!
Ahhh...
I like the sound of that!
nope
How 'bout this
alright
Well I guess I just have that
"Stun grenade"?
Who needs that?
Let's do dis!
Oh I like da-
Ohohohoho look at you~
Oh you dangling fuck!
Mark: Ohohoho you adorable little-
Kali: You should see the Brookhaven sign from here.
Mark: WOOOH
Look at you!
Kali: That's where all of this started.
Mark: Ya jade little piece a' shit~
Kali: And that's where you're headed, so clear a path, and be ready for anything.
be ready for anything
Mark: What am I doing?
Kali: Over.
Mark: Clearin' a path?
Where?
Who am I clearin' a path from?
Zombos?
Huuuh!
Does zombo want to fight-oh??
Uhhh??
Huuh?!
Oh ho ho
Hello!
-and bam!
huhu
Laser sight, huh?
I don't need a laser sight for these assholes...
I know
exactly what I'm sighting
and I can hear you all
creepin' up from behind me
boink!
nope
ehh
there we go
what's that?
over there?
baboink, baboink, baboink
ehehehe
who's there?
Who's there!?
eh
🎵-and Bingo was his name-o🎵
🎵-and Deado was his name-o🎵
there we go
Uh-oh!
ah! ah! ah!
AHHHHH!
there we go
jeezums
you asshole
comin' at me like that
waboink!
alright
we got 'em
Was that the last one?
huh??
huh???
can I do mah happy dance?
turn this off, save this a little bit
*creepy machine noises start again*
*imitates creepy machine noise*
*imitates creepy machine noise again*
*imitates creepy machine noise for the third time*
*imitates creepy machine noise for the fourth time*
*imitates creepy machine noise for the fifth time*
Alright, so we got a laser sight but I don't even know if I'm gonna need it
I'm so accurate~
Uhh
plbffff
es-cuse me
What do you think I am, bad?
"Laser Sight"...
Oh not!-
I didn't even need this
I didn't even need this what does this
crumb
What is this crumb?
I guess it doesn't have a battery anymore because they realized how stupid that was
that was
but I was already dead accurate
Am I gonna have any problem with this?
The answer is no.
who's runnin'?
hehehehehehe
Shouldn't have given me the Laser Sight bruh.
hiii... =3
bam!
dead
Anybody else?
Someone's over there.
oh
do I see you?
in the darkness??
in the darkness~??
did i get ya?
HAAHA
got 'em
Kali: We didn't mean for any of this to happen, we were just curious.
How dangerous is it to peek?
Mark: ooh
ohh!
Maybe a little bit... If I had to judge by anything in the city,
and there's a lot of destruction goin' on here...
Maybe that thing!
blam blam blam!
Come at me bro!
Come at me!!
li'l
betch
allllright
who do we got
UOOOO!!
hello!
I'll be with you in a moment.
I'll be with you in a moment please
don't bother me right now
Please just don't bother me right now.
alright so far so goo
hehehehehe
alright
So far so goo.
helloo...
hello there we go what does that guy
have armor on his head or something
There we go.
What did that guy have, armor on his head or somethin'??
all right I don't need this point our
done
Alright I don't need this.
boink
aand we're doneee~
I'm doin' great!
I'm doing great doing wonderfully
indoors you only have to worry about
I'm doin' wonderfully...
Kali: Indoors, you only have to worry about hostiles that can fit through doorways.
house tools that can fit through
doorways outdoors better have enough
Outdoors, you better have enough ammo for the bigger specimens.
ammo for the bigger specimen
what are you talking about bigger oh boy
here we go
Mark: What are you talkin' about bigger?
uuoO!
oh boy
here we go
are you want some buddies you ain't
gonna get none of me
Alright, you want some buddy?
You ain't gonna get none of me.
where's my where's my throwable we're
gonna throw a ball
Where's my-
where's my throwable?
Where's my throwable?
hang on gotta be a throwable here not in
trouble
hang on
gotta be a throwable here...
I need a throwable.
there we go proximity mine yeah
there we go
Proximity Mine...
ehh!
uo oh
Oh any night for our proximity enough Oh
dad I didn't need two of them
That ain't, that ain't
far proximity enough.
huOOOho
dead
I didn't need two of em!
I thought I would...
I thought I would into that building you
need to make your way to the basement
Kali: When you get into that building, you need to make your way into the basement,
and get one of the backup generators the
generator won't provide enough power for
and get one of the backup generators going.
The generator won't provide enough power for more than emergency lighting
more than emergency lighting but it will
let you use the computers in the
But it will let you use the computers in the observatory.
observatory
ok that is clear it's time to move
Mark: ookay?
Kali: Your path is clear, it's time to move.
ah I don't know about time to mow orgies
Mark: uhh...
Kali: Kali out.
Mark: I dunno about time to move!
uoooo jeez!
Alright, we're doing pretty good
we're doing pretty good not bad i kind
of shifted off my Center it doesn't
not bad
I kind of shifted off of my center.
It doesn't require me to move a whole lot.
require me to move a whole lot of room
for being a lot more stressful than the
I remember it being a lot more stressful in the other one.
other one
but let's see how it is in the lab
but let's see how it is in the lab I'm
not sure I'm not sure how far until like
I'm not sure
uh
I'm not sure how far until like,
I'm not sure how long this game is but
let's see like see what we got at least
I'm not sure how long this game is but let's see like,
let's see what we got at least.
lab basement
"Lab basement"!
well that's good hopefully is more
spoopy is I've seen all this year before
Oh that's good...
hopefully it's more spoopy
'Cause I've seen all this shit before
the first area was good with that jump
scare who this is poopy looking
The first area was good
with that jumpscare
oooh this is spoopy lookin~
who me likey Marky like oh shit
oooh me likey~!
Marky like!
Oh shit
Kali: [unintelligible] --To your location.
Oh can get your current us
Mark: Uh oh.
Kali: But I can't get your current location.
Mark: aww shit
yeah you found that helpful . the movies
Kali: If you found that generator, it can make a hell of a racket while starting up...
Mark: ooh
Kali: The noise will attract attention from hostiles.  You need to protect
oh I power
Mark: ohh I-
Kali: that generator until it's at full power.
uh-huh I got a bad feeling about this
Mark: ahhh
Kali: Over.
I gotta bad feelin' about this
I got four areas lots of places to be
ambushed
I got four areas
lots of places to be ambushed
I'm gonna die oh shit oh shit bullshit
bullshit this ain't good
I'm gonna die...
ooh shit, ooh shit
ooh shit
ooh shit this ain't good
wooh shit
bullshit whoa
wooo!
oh no it's gonna get something BAM bitch
is going to get a whole lot of something
Hooo nelly this is gonna get somethin'
bam bitch!
This is gonna get a whole lot of somethin'
whoo whoo
wooo!
wooooo!
wow that shit
uuh oh!!
uahh shit
okay
ok come on bring it on give me some hard
Come on, bring it on!
Gimme somthin' hard!
oh boy whoa boy
ohh boy
Woohhh boy
I hear 'em!
I hear him you're on I'm here I'm coming
I hear-
AHHHH!!
I hear em comin'
woahhhh
watch it okay we got it we got it we got
it we got it we're good . okay we're
shit
AHHHH!
okay we got it
we got it, we got it
we got it!
we're good
boink
okay we're good
good
who knew it Oh Paul
oooo nelly
ohhh
ohhhhhh
ohoho~
okay so far so goo well i can tell this
is gonna get real bad if i was playing
okay
So far so goo.
woo!
I can tell this is gonna get real bad
if I was playing survival mode...
survival mode in this one
in this one,
hoo boy
whoo boy whoa Nelly Nelly
woahh nelly
ooh nelly
*horse noise*
oh hey I don't want to wait around for
those guys to start chasing you and him
oh hey
I don't wanna wait around for those guys to start chasin' me
I wanna hit 'em harrrd
heard him fast and heard what how you're
not dead
hit 'em fast and haerrrd
why are you not dead??
there we go who ok that's gonna be a
doozy
there we go
ooh
okayy
that's gonna be a doozy
that's gonna be a real doozy
that's going to be a real doozy I keep
checking this door because i'm paranoid
I keep checking this door 'Cause I'm paranoid that someone's gonna come barging through...
that someone is going to come barging
through
There's no one else here.
no one else here but you never know
But you never know.
There's *always* a risk
the always a risk i'm gonna try to do
this one without the last night just to
I'm gonna try to do this one without flashlight
just to make it interesting
make it interesting because there's
plenty of fire
cuz there's plenty of fire
I wanna go back to my old gun
I'm gonna go back to my old gun the
defender and hopefully you can give me
the Defenderrra~
And hopefully it can give me somethin' good
something good
what do we got oh now we're getting
spoopy or an hour getting major spewpa
What do we got?
ohhh now we're gettin' spoopy
ohh now we're gettin' major spoopy doop in here
given here
I hear you
oop
ooh
I see you ok
I see you
okay
hey buddy or is it scary
hey buddy
ohh this is scary!
heh
yeah but like oh shit no joke
heh!
like oooh shit
no joke
well too close too close too close
woahhh!
too close! too close! too close!
ohh god
Oh God Oh Nellie
ohhhh
nelly
ok oh jesus oh jesus oh Jesus okay here
we go
ahh!
okay
ohhh jeez
ohhh jeezums
ohhh jeezum
okay
here we go
take that look away yeah
Take that!
Look away!
wooooo!
oh that's bullshit
uhh thats
ahh!
aw shit
ahhhh!!
ok holy goddamn it
okay
hoooly
god damn
ahhhhhhhhhhhhhhh!!!!
ow...
well he's ok he did i'm about to be did
I should have just been shooting them
ohhh jeez
ok he dead
I'm
about to be dead
I should've just been shooting him from the get-go
from the get-go that flash bang did
nothing
that flash bang did nothing
everything's tinted red
everything's tinted red eye doesn't mean
good boy
that dudn't mean good
oh boy
yeah
ok
one hell of a recoil on this gun
There's one hell of a recoil on this gun
well oh oh oh ok
hoo!
hoooo!
ohh okay
I come at me bruh
Alright come at me bruh
yeah
oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy
ohh boy
hoh boy
oh boy, oh boy, oh boy, OH BOY!
oh boy mama mama i like three loans
really damn it
RELOAD! RELOAD DAMMIT
WOO!
wow wow the Wild West up in there
WOO~!
the wild west up in here!
whoa I can't see a goddamn thing we were
up to where the limitations of
woo!
Mark: I can't see a god damn thing!
Kali: I hate to think what we were up to in that place.
Mark: woo!
Kali: The limitations of spaceflight imaging technology being as they were-
Mark: ahh
Kali: -having seen as much as we could in our three-dimensional universe,
we saw it.
What can we see where we haven't been looking?
How far into the fog could we pierce? Could we see the past? The future? Could we see...other dimensions entirely?
Mark: UM?
I, I, I'm imagining that you figured that shit out...
which isn't a good thing
ohh boy
uh oh
oh, ok, we're good
hoo!
nelly
woo
that was-
that was intense...
nnno joke, that got really scary there for a second
like
I haven't played a VIVE game in a while, but having it looming like right here in my face...
It-it's...It's good.  I can't wait for this to get better.  Okay!
I gotta do health this time
because I'm some carnival pills
oh man those a Molotov cocktail
available in that one
damn it all right I'm going back to the
specter because i need to hire fiery
because what happens is the gun the gun
itself kicks back but this time I'm not
going to do a laser sight
I'm gonna do other...
I'm just going to standard. I like to get
myself challenges still no still no uh
still no, uh, flashlight
it's more interesting that way. Oh, Nellie.
well okay starting right off are we
Where you at?
You down there? Oh I see you
ok, that guy is down. There you go. Oh, did he dodge, or did he get knock to the
side there for a second
come on
There we go. Oh this is much more
interesting- without the laser siight
I actually have to aim
I do I hear...? Oh boy
Ok got him. It's just a matter of putting as
many bullets in him as possible
There we go. Alright, so far gooood~.
Do I hear the thumpy-thump of another?
Oh hey. Hi friend!
Woooah, hey buddy.
Woah-kay! We got it!
Woo, man. I don't even have any time to be
sassy about this. Gettin' a little panic
inducing
I haven't seen any other upgrades like
blue boxes I've been looking for him but
I don't see him
What they doing to me? Well they're not
giving me what I need and what I need is
a lot of help. A lot of help. A looot of help. Uh-oh. You're getting too close for me.
Woooah boy. Wooooah boy. WOOOAH BOY. Woahboy.
Get dead- get dead- woah jeez.
Wooah, Nelly! Oh Nelly!
Baaaamalama~!
Bamalama!
Reload! There you go.
Woo! WooOOooooOO!
*"Woo" in whale noises*
Okay.
Kali: Satellite feed shows me the emergency light are on.
Kali: Move toward the observatory and get me that data.
Mark: Woo!
Kali: Kali out.
Mark: Okay.
Mark: You got it baby!
I'm here for yooou! Woo, we did it. Okay, we did it. Wow.
holy shit oh my god
I apologize for not being very
talkative these rounds
I'm just in a tizzy about getting
through this without dying
which I'm doing better at but I need
more guns, is what in need. I need a lot more
guns
I'm gonna get him though. All right, I
think that's the last level the
observatory
let's try let's do it I'm down I'm down
to clown
Just do it.
Ok, hello.
Where- why is it back there? Well, that better not be- what?
What? Why that way? Why is that the front now? But I need to-
Huh...
well you're going to see a lot of my ass
in this round sorry about that and
less that what you wanted, I don't know
Kali: This is Kali. I've got you locked in, good work.
I'm opening the tunnel to that PC. Our signal being to weak, there's no way
download hundreds of gigs of data remotely.
But, I can run that machine from here
and download the relevant data to your drive
Mark: Uh huh.
Kali: Stay safe while I get the transfer going. Over.
Mark: Stay safe?
Mark: Woah what is that up there?
Kali: Okay, the data transfer
has started.
Kali: Just locked the copy, so
you're going to have to defend against hostiles.
Mark: Greaaat! Good to know. From behind, I gotta
Mark: Shoot them from behind my head.
Blam blam, from back.
Blah-blah.
Blah!
Blah blah!
Yeh-okay I'm gonna get it. Waddu you want?! when
do you want it
Death?
Boy, it is dark without that flashlight
whoo hello buddy
got ya! Uh-oh whoa who's who's big
where is big? I hear big. Woah, where the hell is big?
Am I losing my goddamn mind? I hear big. Woah boy. Wooah boy.
I hear big! down there? where the fuck. I'm
losing my goddamn mind.This is- woah. Aah, saw you!
oh boy, oh boy
I see it down there I see you but- AAAH
Oh fuck! Ooooh my god! Oh jeez, oh jeez, oh jeez.
I got him. head clean off wow ok i did
not even know i did not even know that
front was an option.
Wooooo~!
It is... Okay, so there are from the front.
So you won't see as much of my ass as you wanted to see but
you're going to see a lot of it
if I could just get another gonna be
really fucking happy- oh boy
okay i'm gonna get the laser set again
because it's getting dicey in here and I
don't want to be messing around with
nothing
woo it's bad enough I can't even see with the
flashlight let alone without of a newly
Kali: Have you seen the babies?
they're newly hatched and vicious little things.
don't let them gang up on you. Mark: What?! the
babies?!
Mark: what are you talking about the babies?!
that doesn't make any goddamn sense the
last time I saw a zombie baby it was dead
space. that doesn't sound like a baby.
Oh, oh!
AAAH, boink!
Wait, where are you? Woah, jeez.
Oh, jeez.
Where'd you go? I thought there were more of ya. Hey buddy.
Oh, the laser sight is so much
better than actually havin' skill. Weeeh.
Alright, someone comes down that hallway again,
we'll fuck him up
Fuck him up!
Where you at bruh?
I don't see ya.
Where you at? I know you're down there.
Oh-oh-oh-oh I see ya. I see ya now.
Woah, that's someone else.
Woah, jeez!
NOOOO!
Bam, bitch! Bam, bitch! Where you at?
Got you. Hang on.
Got you! Okay.
Got you!- woah.
That doesn't sound good.
Woah-woah-woah-woah- I see something.
Woooah.
Woooah, woooah, babies! Babies!
I don't want to see you up close, thank you very much
I don't wanna see none of ya up close- Bam, bitch! Who, who the heck
oh shit
who did that? shit-shit-shit... baam, baby! execution-style execution-style who's coming from where
Eh!
Woo-ba-dee-boop!
nice got you nailed ya in the face. Nailed ya in the face.
fuck off right now! Nailed ya in the face.
um yeah, I'm such a good shooter yeah.
looking mean, at the people in the FAAACE!
fuck you fuck you fuck you fuck you fuck
you fuck you fuck you fuck you fuck off
With! You! Fu- oh I thought I saw one over there.
Fuck oooooff~!
Still don't see any goddamn upgrade!
Fuck thiiiiis~!
Hah-heyyy!! Nice!
okay so they're hidden I don't know why
I expect them not to be hidden.
Oh well, good enough for me, right?
Woooo!
I did it!
Oh man! Woo! I did this! Bam!
Blam! Bam! Bam! Bam! It's somewhere down there.
Kali: All we meant to do, was all
opening into another realm
Kali: People, we called it.
Mark: Oh, shut up.
Kali: but as quantum physics holds you cannot
observe without affecting the observed
Kali:What we saw, we stared at too long, for
apparently it saw us back.
Mark: Umm... um...
Kali: It tore that people into a gateway.
Kali: Atleast I hope it's a gateway, because
that implies it can be closed.
Mark: Hueh, hueh, tore that people
Mark: ok all right then tore that people into a
goatsy hole, if you know what I'm talking
about
well then you shouldn't have dabbled
with things beyond your comprehension
hello and if I know anything about
quantum physics
that's not how quantum physics work with
what you described
hello
where-where-where? There ya are.
Woo! ok.
got him who's out there huh
who goes there I need to save my battery
- eh, shit
whoa come down there? WoahohohohOOOOH! Good thing I got this extended bitch
Uh-oh.
Eh! Eh!
what do they mean that they just hatched?
that would like- coming down there? Woah
that would imply that they're growing
these things which isn't very good
It's gettin' dicey. Wooah, gettin' dicey.  Woahh, babies, babies, babies
babies babies babies- woah woah woah! Just,
fucking babies!
jeezums! get him off my shoes
okay well i'm almost out of battery- which ain't a good thing.
can't hide from me! What, where'd you go?
there we go well is moderately
terrifying
baby baby baby baby talking baby
woah jeez. I thought I heard something. Did I hear something?
Something coming up there? ok give me a goddamn
break
Waah-boink! Do I have a breather?
Wah, what was that? shit. I hear noises outside
of my house
all right we're good. woo! probably only one more round to go after this
and then we're done
shut up! yeah I don't like the sound of that. Where they at? Where they at? Woah, jeez. Where they at?
Woah, hey, little buggers!
you want some, huh?!
god damn it you're tough! Ahhh! AHHH!
crap fucking bastard bitches fuck you
who's there what the fuck I'm in trouble
AHHH! FUCKIN', FUCK!
fuck you fuck you fuck you man god I
can't see anything oh jeez.  I see your
buggers
AHHH GODDAMN IT! Ah, fuuuck you! Woo, woah, this is bad.This is bad. How much battery? Ah,
leaving battery on. can't see a god damn thing
ok, woo!
Wow fucking fuck those silent
you need sound! Hear, hear!
Kali: Good. The transfer is complete and I'm
logged off.  that last drive is
Mark: Ah, good.
now the most important thing that exists
in our world. you must get it to me no
matter what it takes
Kali: streets are overrun the
observatory should have a shaft connects
Mark: Okay, I got it! *farting noises*
to a storm drain
follow the flames.
Mark: Wait, you telling me that
to go to a sewer next you tell me a
hundred percent that my next level is a
sewer
because i don't like sewer levels in
horror games
whore whore all right well that is the
case then i guess i'm i'm continuing
going on let me let me see how many
levels there are first and I'll be right
back
is that a little evaluate because i've
been recording for about 45 minutes now
oh hello! oh! and front and center again
guten! guten morgen! your lap
basement ok I did basement did the
observatory
wait a minute wait are you kidding me
Oh next don't be good ah there's a lot
more ok and then next
oh there's tons more
ok so i'm not even close to done with
this so anyway I'll leave it at that
it's I mean is it's technically going to
be more of the same but i imagine that
this time goes on there going to unlock
more and more monsters so i'll leave it
up to you if you guys want to see more
of this game let me know in the comments
below
I really need your opinion on this if
you want to see this game fully play
because it's a lot of fun so I'm more
than happy to play but let me know down
in the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video.
Buh-bye!